[Music]
next week Mortal Kombat X in Grand Theft
Auto 5 on PC hit store shelves and I
guess there's nothing particularly
fascinating about them except if you'd
said this to me 15 years ago I probably
would have breathed the sigh of relief
you see you're an the turn of the
century it seemed you couldn't read an
article about videogames in the press
but at violence being dragged into the
conversation how games were created to
prey on kids fascination with gore and
how video games made children violent
and decrease their pro-social behavior
in 2015 the violence in games debate is
much less of a talking point our
industry has grown up and now we're free
to talk about issues that actually
matter but that's not to say that the
games price isn't guilty of being
reactionary from time to time the season
3 episode 10 censorship in the world of
the press quick little history lesson
back in the early 90s Mortal Kombat was
causing quite the stir a moral panic
over the game's use of violence
especially the fatalities resulted in
Congress getting involved at the
hearings expert testimony from professor
Eugene Perez know at the U stated that
games have almost TV quality graphics
but are overwhelmingly violent sexist
and racist and while mk2 wasn't banned
that the find the story was front page
news and the public reaction resulted in
the eventual establishment of the es or
B's game rating system that we still use
today censorship is a tricky subject but
there was no shortage of figures willing
to pick up this ball and run with it
Senator Joe Lieberman wanted to ban all
violent video games Hillary Clinton
attempted and failed to pass the family
entertainment protection plan while
subsequently the spired attorney Jack
Thompson spent a career beating on grand
theft auto this was the era of my video
game teenage years games I wasn't meant
to be playing music would explicit
lyrics labels that I shouldn't be
allowed to hear and sneaking into adult
rated movies that I wasn't meant to be
allowed to see for me is a consumer of
media the world was against me I was to
be protected and sheltered from the
evils of society because a video games
were for kids and b games are capable of
changing people's mindsets of their
reality
me and it seemed like you couldn't have
a conversation about video games that
had violence being dragged into the mix
and for a kid who loved games and loved
talking to people about them it was
absolutely maddening why couldn't people
talk about my hobby without bringing up
all this tangental nonsense and why was
i apologizing for this obviously
fantastic world of creativity I was
confused why all the conversations
around the social implications of video
games managed to grow so large that they
seemed to eclipse the sum of all that
was good about this medium I was angry
and I needed someone to blame so I
blamed those who I believed are in a
position to stop it I blamed the hosts
of video game television shows I blamed
the useless journalists who would go on
TV debates about game violence and [__]
it up I blamed people who I saw were in
a fortunate enough position to be
bastions for our hobby and failed to
protect it that's why I wanted to break
into the games price and that's what I
did I used to drive and talk on radio in
my spare time I was in college when I
had jobs I remember working in Game Stop
and using my lunch breaks to hop on the
phone and get him radio debates about
the gaming issues of the day and
eventually through doing that a bunch I
became the go-to debater for Ireland's
most popular current events talk show so
when the latest controversy kicked up
I'd be there with a shield of knowledge
to barter away any straw man arguments
and I did nervous but prepared I fought
the sight of gamers when manhunt too was
banned in Ireland when drink-driving
organisations wanted to do the same to
Grand Theft Auto 4 you know I thought
any sensible initiative to reduce teen
driving on our roads but basically
that's the crux of the eyes of in math
and does is there's video games of
difference the movies because you're in
a sense acting it out but you're not
you're using a controller I'm proud of
these moments to me the world of games
was under attack by people who are
twisting the facts to suit their own
agenda and as somebody who just loved
games I found that impossible to stomach
so you can probably see where this is
going right in going back to write a
script about the history of game
violence I couldn't help but be struck
by the parallels that exist between my
feelings about games journalists all
those years ago
and the frustrations that many gamers
have with the press today I find it
fascinating actually today seems that
gamers around the world
they're fed up with the amount of
attention that the price is giving to
social issues things like racism
homophobia transphobia gender equality
so from the outside it looks like this
whole gaming bubble is just a massive
pile of bigot so why is this happening
what the hell is going on now somebody
who thinks that games should be
encouraged to tackle difficult and
social political issues I'm frustrated
by this I want people to think of games
as progressive and clearly so do most of
the games press the world of video games
reporting has evolved and today it's
common that articles news posts and even
reviews talk about games in a wider
cultural context but this is angered a
lot of gamers they're frustrated by what
they perceive as individual ideologies
being forced upon their games that games
have become a battlefield for issues
that largely don't concern them that
games are being held to an unreasonably
high moral standard and that just as the
mainstream press did during the days of
the violent games debate the video game
price will jump on any old controversy
just to drive traffic and while I
completely wholeheartedly disagree that
these issues should be taken off the
critical table there is something to be
said for games price taking logical
leaps in service of their own opinion
and ultimately I think that benefits
nobody take the far cry for box art
controversy when several sites
incorrectly assumed that the antagonist
pagan min was a Caucasian male a leap
made largely because of the controversy
surrounding far cry 3's supposedly
racist themes or when Assassin's Creed
unity was criticized for not having a
female character model for online play
it subsequently transpired that you
couldn't select different male models
either the game simply defaulted to the
single player character Arno gaming has
come a long way in a short number of
years conversations about gender race
and sexuality didn't happen 15 10 or
even five years ago and the fact that
they do now
is something we should all be incredibly
proud of but this shouldn't be a shield
to protect unfettered reactive criticism
this type of reporting doesn't serve
anyone not gamers not developers and
certainly not those who put their necks
on the line to make gaming as inclusive
as it is today in 2015 for me growing
off the games price was guilty of
inaction today they are guilty of being
too reactive to holding games up to
lofty personal expectations and
punishing the ones that fall short and
that's why some gamers are
Stav because they view this as an abuse
of influence I think it's critically
important that games become more
inclusive and I think it's critically
important that we allow developers the
space to make whatever games they want
to even if we don't agree with them
games should be allowed to tackle social
issues and they should be allowed to be
reckless and dumb I want an industry
where we can enjoy gone home for one
reason and Grand Theft Auto 5 for
another but the only way we can achieve
this is if we understand when a game is
doing something fundamentally wrong and
when it's doing something we simply
don't like
you
[Music]